the first day i ever laced up a pair of
boxing gloves and went to a gym
it felt like home
the world's watching and there's no
lying no faking no excuses in that 25
minutes of that fight it's the truth
[Music]
the truth i'm addicted to that your fire
is felt
from the moment i walked into a gym
and i started lacing up these boxing
gloves
a thought of money was never on my mind
it was always to be the best
everybody stand up and give it up to the
one and only dustin pottier what's
happening
how you doing doing good man excited to
be here yeah we're excited to have you
everybody was looking forward to this uh
dustin you know before we got i got a
lot of things to cover with you with
your history
but before we uh get into it the
audience just so you know who you're
speaking to raise your hand again so he
knows who you are anybody is a founder
here that runs their own businesses
raise your hand so these are founders
anybody's a c-suite executive ceo you
run your own business maybe you're doing
a million dollars or more raise your
hand any businesses you run raise your
hand okay
any sales people if you run sales or
sales leaders raise your hand from 150
different industries just so you know
who your audience is yeah
nobody here can fight you and beat you
up so you're safe i don't we're worried
anyways but i just want to put that
disclaimer out there i'm off today i'm
not fighting anybody
that's good so dustin before we get
started for some guys that don't know
your story
uh and they don't know how you came up
you got a pretty crazy story yourself if
you don't mind taking a moment and
sharing with everybody your story that'd
be great to just get started with that
oh yeah i'm i don't know how far back i
should start but go from eighth grade go
from when you were in school
and you know some decisions you made and
what you did go go back yeah so um
in eighth grade i was getting in a lot
of trouble um running with with the
wrong crowd of people i uh ended up
going to juvenile detention for a while
when i got out i
started ninth grade and stopped so i
never graduated ninth grade
and um
was just kind of running around
aimlessly
without a goal without something to work
work towards and and growing up i always
loved combat sports and uh at what age
like how soon was it as far back as i
can remember oh really yeah i remember
uh getting excited going to friend's
house for mike tyson fights
when he was fighting holyfield and i
just always loved boxing boxing was was
what i wanted to do
um and eventually i met some guys at a
boxing gym who were doing mixed martial
arts they were just working on their
striking and i went to their gym and the
story's history you know it just
snowballed into a career of fighting
but
that when i was younger and and when i
dropped out of school finding combat
sports the thing for me was when i was
watching these guys fight the grit and
determination that they showed i just
for some reason knew i had that whatever
that was i knew i could do that didn't
know if i could fight with the best guys
in the world but i knew i was willing to
suffer more than the next guy and you
knew that i knew that
i knew that whatever they had i had
how old were you when you got your first
fist fight first fist fight like a legit
fight
i would probably say 13 years old maybe
do you remember that fight i've had so
many of them i've had so many of them
so 13 years old uh if somebody was to
say you know everybody has a reputation
at that age some kid was the athlete
some kids the good looking guys some
kids the gangsters some kids the guy
that does baseball cars video games 13
years old what was your reputation
the guy who did whatever he want you
know i just
did whatever i want i didn't really
not that that's a good thing or boasting
about it i just whatever i felt like
doing i did whether it was
um against the law or against my mother
asking me not to i just kind of did what
i wanted to do
and i still do that these days just
much more focused and doing it the right
way that same energy i had i use it in
the right way now very cool very cool so
when you're coming up at 13 at what
point did you kind of get a feel
that
i think i can fight
pretty good against some of these guys
what did you have a moment where you're
like i think i can really compete with
some of these guys the first day i ever
laced up a pair of boxing gloves and
went to a gym
and started sweating and just the
camaraderie of the other other guys in
there fighting and
i just it felt like home that's where i
wanted to be with those guys and and i
mean from that day i i never looked back
and i completely changed my circle and
changed my focus and kind of just got
drowned
and lost in that and it's still that
for me what was that in lafayette was it
in new orleans or was it was it here
lafayette lafayette yeah coming up and
who were some of the guys that were
mentoring you was there any names uh did
you have gyms you went to where there
was you know reputable boxers
so i went to a
mixed martial arts gym it was the only
one in lafayette at the time but the the
tv show ultimate fighter i'm not sure if
you've heard of it sure it was just
starting to like be a big thing that was
like when forest griffin fought and it
was on spike tv
one of my one of the guys from louisiana
got a call to be on the show and when he
came back he opened his own gym
and me and all the guys who were at this
other gym went you know we moved to his
gym and i started learning from him and
he was uh the first black belt in jiu
jitsu in louisiana's history
and and he's built a stable of
incredible fighters one uh his guys just
won tuesday night on dana white's
contender series and got a contract in
the ufc wow so i mean
he he was a huge part of my career so
legit like he had a reputation oh yeah
okay was he also like a father figure
brother like older brother guy like you
know kind of direction as well he was
i'm not sure how old he how much older
he is i would say at least seven eight
years older than me but he had his stuff
together he went to for me you know he
went to college he was running a
business
he was married so he definitely was a
father figure got it so good example by
the way just so you know
you don't need to worry about your past
many of us have similar paths here i'm a
one-pointed gpa kid in high school
divorced family there was nothing going
in the right direction my savior was
military instead of you know you went
fighting i went in the army that was my
direction and then i got i went in
business so at this point
what year would it be because i'm trying
to see going back during that time was
what pride was going on yeah what was
someone who ufc had just bought pride
around that time got it so those big
names like rampage jackson and vandalise
sofa those guys were just coming over to
the ufc so it was an exciting time in
mixed martial arts the ifl was really
big back wow you're taking it back so
yeah
holy moly because you're you're what are
you are you january 16th 89 what what
years uh you're uh january 19th 89th
general in 1989. so you're 30 30 uh two
years old yeah 32 years old whooping
some ass how awesome is that by the way
right when you think about that freaking
amazing
okay so
you know you said you watched tyson who
else were some of the guys that you
modeled were you my mom um
when when the muhammad ali movie came
out will smith we went she brought me
opening night just because she knew i
was also
very uh big into the
how muhammad ali did what he did what he
thought was right against
uh everyone's judgment you know not
going to war getting his title stripped
that's powerful you know to put your
foot down
so you respect it i i respect him who do
you think is the modern day ali right
now who would you say
ali
oh man that the landscape of combat
sports has changed so much
i can't put a name to that one that's a
tough one
so you got tyson
you got ali by the way i remember that
movie when it first came out great movie
well crushed it in that movie yeah the
story was fantastic i think they're
working on a tyson movie right now
they're working on a title movie right
now we had we had tyson on
two weeks ago we had an event at mgm
grand arena and we had tyson at the
event and it was
very uh different kind of a uh uh
hearing his story and he told the story
he said when i was nine years old
i had fifty five hundred dollars in my
pocket because i was street fighting
and i was knocking kids fathers out
at nine years old he said so i knocked
out this kid and this kid went and
grabbed his dad then i knocked his dad
out
and he says the first time i had a fight
he says here's how i fought he says i
closed my eyes and i went like this and
i saw the guy on the floor i'm like oh
i can knock people out
was there a moment where you were kind
of like
i can pack a punch
just being in the gym and fighting the
guys who were established already guys
who were professional fighters and and i
was still an amateur
doing well holding my own with those
guys i knew it but like i said before i
even
put those gloves on i knew i can do this
you know i just had i just had i was
overconfident in it but also as i got
older i realized how much goes into this
like ignorance is bliss when you're that
young i'm just showing it to the gym
thinking i'm going to beat everybody and
of course you continue to grow and get
better skill wise but you get humbled
through the process
so so when the ultimate fighter who who
was the ultimate fright when he started
first following it so i remember there
was who was the guy that yes yes oh
diego sanchez diego sanchez while he
used to be very entertaining i remember
watching him years ago but who was the
ultimate fighter back then when you were
five it was uh forrest griffin and
stephen bonner that's when it really
blew up and and
ufc was on the map when that fight
happened so your route isn't necessarily
ufc you started off with what is it
extreme uh cage fighting am i saying oh
wec wec and you started there and
walk us through that because i think you
have two fights there the first one you
actually lost and it was the first
second first loss first loss of my
professional career
and first loss on your professional
career yeah
that was a heartbreaker for me because
fighting locally in louisiana as a
professional i was
wasn't making a lot of money but
sponsorships and um
you know people knew me there so we can
fill out arenas and make i can make a
little bit of money enough to
support me and my wife because me and my
wife um
we've been married 12 years and we
bought a house when we were 19 years old
so i had a mortgage you know i had grown
man bills and i was a young kid trying
to fight and make money wow
you've been married 12 years yeah and
she's in a bag yeah yeah i saw your wife
and a mac that's cool married 12 years
at 19 years old you guys are still
together that's i mean what's the secret
sauce there you're all over every
magazine every tv everywhere how you
making your marriage work
i just got lucky and got the right one
you know she's my best friend and uh
i think i think i wouldn't have
accomplished a lot without her so
awesome
that's great
so
you have the first fight
sometimes if you're coming out and your
first bite kind of doesn't go your way
can psychologically mess with you did it
do anything to you or did the coach kind
of come back and say it's okay it's not
a big deal yeah here's the thing so i
thought
that the world extreme cage fighting was
a big organization it was on tv
um you know the championships were
respected and i was fighting on the
local scene i got a fight up in canada
and that's what got me signed to the wec
so i was so excited to go to vegas for
my first time you know traveling acro
across the country to fight nobody's
gonna be on tv
i get out there and i lose and then i
get my check and and i thought i was
gonna i was here i was gonna make it
life's about to change now
and then uh
medicals are deducted from my check my
my coaches flights are deducted for my
check
all these things and i'm
i can't survive on this when i got the
check i was making more money fighting
locally so it was a heartbreaking moment
for me wow
yeah so we got back home reevaluated
some things and just kept my foot on the
gas
but yeah that was a heartbreaker my
first loss as a professional how big was
the check can you was it a five ten
thousand twenty thousand dollars
i think i was making four thousand
dollars
to to show up the way fighting works
with mixed martial arts at the beginning
you get a show and a win if you win you
get the other half of your purse so i
was making like three or four thousand
dollars i lost so i didn't get the other
half
and then everything was deducted you
know
as a young kid i don't know how much
flights really cost they're booking i'm
letting them book my my coaches flights
it's 600 dollars for his flight you know
and i have a few coaches so i get my
check and i might have like 1200 bucks
and i got to fly back home and look at
my wife you know we didn't have money
for her to go
i didn't even have money to get the
hotel room you know
and um that's your first fight that was
my first loss as a professional how how
did you not get like you're coming back
so you're coming back and your wife is
saying babe
we didn't make no money on this one yeah
we lost money on this yeah so was there
ever a time where you're like i just
don't think this is the world for me to
be and i got to go figure out another
way to make money did you ever have that
moment there's been a few times in my
career i've had that am i talking about
those moments
yeah i that that was one of them the
first time i thought conor mcgregor was
another one
i was close to a title shot i was ranked
in the top two in the world and
i went out there and got beat by a guy
who was running his mouth and and saying
all these things you know um
and and when i got back home i was just
like looking in the mirror what saying
what am i doing here like what am what's
going on i put everything i had into
this and i went out there and lost
and and i just was that was 2014 2014.
seven years you were 25 years old at the
time yeah
but i was on on a good streak like it
was me or him who were gonna fight for
the belt yeah
and uh i took that loss and that one
really all they all hurt
but
just got back home and i usually when
when those things happen
i drown myself in the work so i don't
think about it i just get back in the
gym every day working grinding and it
takes my mind off of off of those
do you have another routine to stay
mentally stable and calm like
do you and your wife do you say babe you
can't talk to that guy that guy's
negative you can't call this person or
hey do you do reading books audio mute
what is your way of keeping yourself
calm
in training or just in general just no
you're coming back so i mean your record
is about 28 and six am i saying it
correctly
are you 20
what's your record your my professional
record i think is 28 and six okay so
meaning like you know we run businesses
man not every decision we make we take
losses all the time so there isn't
anybody in that world that's not going
to have their moment except we got one
guy and that one guy if he continues
fighting maybe somebody could get him
you know we're talking about khabib
right outside of him yeah but for the
most part everybody has eventually that
they're going to take a loss how do you
process a loss because here's the
difference that that gang we have a
different way of losing versus
dustin in his world when we lose is in
an office 19 people hear about a loss
you know what i'm saying when we lose oh
maybe people find that at a regional in
front of a hundred people it's just that
we're running a real estate company
whatever business when you guys fight
the world is what the world is watching
you how do you manage that loss
i get back home and i try to not only in
fighting but in my life i make dumb
mistakes all the time and uh
in fighting when i make a mistake that
gets me caught or gets me in trouble and
i lose a fight
i try not to make it again that that's
you know being better than yesterday is
is my goal every day i wake up and
in in fighting and in life that's what i
do what led to this mistake how can i
tighten up and not do this again
just try to learn from it you know
and i i try to live my life that way do
you watch tapes like do you sit there
and you watch the fight after fight or
no you guys don't watch the fight
i have to let it breathe a little bit
depends how it yeah
i have to let the emotions kind of get
out of me so i can really digest what
i'm watching and try to break it down
but me and my team will sit down and
replay the fight and and see things that
we were doing wrong and we could do
better always is your the team that you
have around you are they those who
are comfortable telling you the truth to
say dustin i don't know why you did this
you know not to do this you did this
three times of training do they talk too
pretty yeah like level of accountability
is very open have to be in fighting
because there's no lying in there
you know it's not like
i don't know how it is in the in the
business office world like i can't you
might be able to cover some stuff with
some white out and change some numbers
here and there
the world's watching and there's no
lying no faking no excuses in that 25
minutes of that fight
it's the truth
and that's honestly that's the only
thing i still love about this sport is
that the fight is the truth because
everything's so fabricated and online
and people have opinions it's just
the truth i'm addicted to that yeah the
truth is going to be revealed in that
octagon it's kind of everyone's you can
talk all you want yeah and those guys
around me you know i don't have yes men
around me those guys
cut it straight very cool that's great
so
coming up so you do your first two
fights and then ufc 2011 i think you
start going into ufc you're coming up at
what point did the world kind of realize
this this guy's legit what was the one
fight that you had when everybody
started saying he's legit i had a unique
opportunity coming from the wec
when i was signed to the wec ufc bought
the company so they merged all the
fighters onto their roster
and the guy named jose aldo if you're a
fight fan you know
legendary world champion jose aldo is he
was getting ready to fight a guy named
josh grisbe
on a new year's card in the mgm grand in
las vegas
and jose heard his neck
and they needed like a tune-up keep the
guy ready for when jose's healthy and
they called me
and i actually got the call i was in the
gym training on the mats when i got the
call so i was in the right spot
and they they asked me to cut down to
145 pounds for this opportunity to fight
the number one contender what were you
at that time when they called you i was
fighting at 155 pounds but i was
probably 180 something so you had to cut
down 30
45 pounds
yeah 120
that's right 25 yeah but when dana white
calls you and you're a young kid and
this is going to be your first fight in
the ufc you say yes 155 or 145. this one
was 145. i've never made that in my in
my my career as a fighter amateur or a
pro until that call
when when those fights happen does a
dana call or does somebody on dana's
team call your camp and say hey is he
ready to fight
usually it's somebody um
in the office at the ufc but on these
kind of things dana will call so dana
calls
and then who comes and tells you hey you
got a big fight potentially coming i was
i was in the gym so my coach my buddy
tim who was on the ultimate fighter came
and said hey it's happening you're going
to the ufc and we kind of knew that
because the company bought the wc got it
so we knew we were going to be merged
over but i didn't know it was going to
be that soon you know i might have had a
few weeks to prepare
but i went in there and you asked me
when i felt like i got on the scene i
went in there and i unanimous decision
over the number one contender at 145
pounds it's pretty sick and made a big
splash yeah and that's 10 years ago you
were 21 years old yeah
guys that's pretty insane to do
something like that
okay so now you leave
now you're saying what's the are you
thinking are you talking to you guys
saying hey listen sky's the limit for us
right now what are you thinking at that
moment that win out of all the wins i've
won the um
the interim championship when i beat max
holloway in atlanta sick thanks and uh
that that first win getting my hand
raised in the ufc for the first time
is still one of the
best feelings most memorable feelings
that i've had because i always thought i
can compete with those guys
but to go in there and beat the number
one contender on short notice i felt
like everything was stacked against me
it really felt like all right like i can
do anything here i can be the world
champion
i mean of course i mean if you're going
at a
with a guy like that at 21 years old
you're not even at your prime yet what
age in this business is prime
everybody's different genetics but for
me the way i look at it is uh you start
off with
your athletic ability to be high and
fighting is so mental it's not only
your skill set and fighting everybody
punches hard everybody's fast at this
level we're all great athletes everybody
works their ass off it's it's there's a
there's a prime moment where the
athletics here and the minds here and
and you start to age and and it comes
down and and when they even out that's
when you're in your prime and
everybody's different but now it's my
time right now you're at your prime
right now yeah you're looking at it
[Laughter]
oh man
so right now like you know who do you
think you can go up against and when is
there any is there any fight that you
would like to see happen where you're
fighting
i'm just waiting on the contract it
looks like i'm going to be fighting for
the lightweight world championship
december 11th in las vegas
yeah and it's against against charles
oliveira really yeah that's not it's not
been signed yet though it's not been
signed let they actually leaked the news
yesterday so it's starting to get out
there but uh i've agreed to it december
11th i'm gonna be the world champion
very cool well we're definitely looking
forward to that so now
the fight when you won uh with the aldo
fight was that actually the first one
where you got a little bit of money did
you get a taste of money there or no
yeah so that was the biggest payday i've
had to that point and i just remember
going home i think we uh paid off my
wife's car i didn't have a car at the
time early in our career i used to ride
a bike to the gym sick my wife would
bring me or borrow my mom's van and go
it was just crazy you know but uh paid
off the car got ahead and put some money
in the bank and then just it's been that
ever since trying to do it the right way
it's amazing that's that's great to see
so okay so then uh now you have the
fight that uh it's coming up in uh uh uh
december you said december's gonna be
the december 11th and uh uh with all the
stuff that's going on there's a few
characters i'm curious about with you so
one you fought a lot of different guys
okay
uh and you fought different styles of
guys in in ufc
who to you
you say when this guy punches it's the
heavy he packs a punch who's above
everybody i know we can say everybody
packs a good punch right was there
anybody that you said i felt this guy's
punch conor mcgregor no doubt about it
you put connor at the top yeah that as
the best biggest puncher i thought yes
yeah
yeah she's special special individual
for sure
wow and and you fought in what you
fought him uh 14 and then 21-21 fought
him in 2014
lost and that was on his
you know in his trajectory was just
sky was the limit he was on his way up
and he tore through everybody became a
two-way world champion
but
yeah and i fought him twice this year
so this year when you get the first
fight the second fight the third fight
do you feel any different when he packs
this punch or is still the same still
the same very dangerous it's just i i've
i felt differently
mentally going into it
you think the biggest difference between
you and 14 21 is mental or is it skills
as well some areas where you saw some
weaknesses where you can exploit
for sure my skills got better over the
years
you know all the work wasn't done in
vain but my middle side is is what lost
me that first fight you know and what
won me these last two fights that's two
fights uh a ground if you were to say
somebody who you went up against went up
against that ground game it's just could
be khabib nurmagomedov
yeah would you put him like in a league
of his own a lot of people call him as
the league of his own type of guy would
you never felt anything like it you know
and i have 46 fights i fought all kind
of different people all kind of
different styles been around the world
training in gyms
this guy
this guy's good what's what's unique
about it tell us about me
his understanding of his weight
distribution where my weight needs to be
to keep me up to build back up and and
his understanding of uh grappling is is
impressive is i mean the best i've ever
felt the best i've ever seen you know
the guys 30-0
and mma that's a hard thing to do
there's so many variables there's so
many ways to lose
and to be 30-0
against the best guys in the world
is
you know very impressive but
his understanding of what i needed to do
and what positions i needed to be in
to advance
he was he was steps ahead of me if if he
decides let's just say you win in
december hypothetically you win fight is
over in your mind you're going to win
the fight so that's over with okay so
now dustin's the guy
you're everywhere right i'm talking
every freak there's everybody has to
come through you you call the shots
if he wanted to and you guys fought in
2022 how confident are you if you went
up against khabib i'm very confident i
can beat anybody in the world
anybody in the world
but at the same time i'm honest with
myself and i understand this combat
sports and and i can lose to anyone as
well
but my skill set i believe 100 percent
of my skill set and work ethic i can
beat anyone
it's exciting to be in that state and
you know what makes you unique is your
level of humility so
in in uh uh uh in the what's been
happening a lot lately is with jake uh
paul tyrone woodley i don't know if you
saw the fight oh you weren't at the
place you were out the fight i saw you
were everywhere yeah what do you think
about the fight jake against tyrone
i thought tyron was gonna do a lot a lot
better than that you know he's been in
the gym
for the last 15 years fighting training
mixed martial arts he's a former world
champion um but he's not about he's a
big puncher but he's not a boxer the art
of boxing is is different
it's um it's a different thing
you think if you like let's i'm not
saying it's going to happen i'm just
saying if you did fight these guys as a
boxer
is there any chance they can go up
against you if they box you i think i
beat all these guys in boxing every one
of these guys yeah these these um social
media guys crossing over yeah yeah i
punish them
confidently it's not even like a thought
i'm not being cocky but i know you're
not being this is how i feed my family
and i've grown up in the gyms and become
a man in these gyms um under the
pressure and fire of fighting so when i
speak about fighting i speak about it
strongly because i care about this stuff
no it's by the way just so you know it's
felt your your fire is felt that's not
you can't act that way it's very natural
so max
max uh uh you know historically is known
as being one of the better boxers in uh
in the mma and you went up against him
twice and you won both times and the
second fight you guys had
sick fight i mean we should have paid
300 to watch that fight was that sick of
a fight what is it like fighting max max
is a guy who um
his
pace is hard to keep up with fortunately
for me i i work hard and build my
aerobic capacity and and my cardio
and muscle endurance but i have a
natural gift i'm thankful for it but i
can be out of shape off the couch and go
to the gym and outlast a lot of these
guys physically
i don't know how why it's just the way
my body's wired so i'm thankful for that
so i was able to keep up with his pace
and make him make mistakes you know he
was the current world champion at the
time he moved up in weight and i beat
him
but
in there i felt his understanding of
combat sports and and i felt his
knowledge and his skill set he's an
incredible fighter
if you were to put of all the people you
fought i'm a dog fight type of person
who would you put at the top not best
puncher not ground i'm talking dogfight
like this guy's not gonna stop he's
relentless who would you put at the top
that i've faced yeah
max has to be at the top you know i've
hit him which i hit him with so many
shots he was hurt multiple times
um another one at the at
that on that list is justin gaichy
i mean the guy's a wrecking ball he he
walks forward with reckless abandonment
for his own body and his own health to
to land his shots
but that's why he's such a fun fighter
to watch very cool do you think connor
is going to make a comeback that injury
man you know he broke the tibia and
phibia that's going to be a long road
but look at all the things the guy's
accomplished if anybody can come back
from that it's him you know i wish him i
don't hate any of these guys it's very
obvious um all the stuff said and and
the
you know
he he could he could you know he's a
former multi multiple time world
champion and he knows how to work he has
money he has a team around him so if he
wants to build it back up he has all the
the things to do that how do you stay
motivated when you're getting paid as
much as he's getting paid
i don't know man did i say it's hard to
wake up and run those miles and when you
sleep in the soap pajamas
[Laughter]
has that happened to you yet have you
made that kind of money like have you
made the money money yet do you feel
like you're at a point right now where
you're feeling pretty confident about
where you're at financially yeah me and
my family are in a great spot and uh
but i still i have things to do i still
have things to do i'm not there yet i
have one more box to check on my career
the ribbon on top of my mixed martial
arts career is be the undisputed world
champion that's what i want that's what
i
from the moment i walked into a gym
the first time in my life and i started
lacing up these boxing gloves i thought
of money was never on my mind it was
always to be the best and i'm still
climbing that mountain you know
you got a guy like tom brady that's how
old is he right now 68 i don't know how
old he is i think he saw
he's like 44 is he 43 or 44 with 44 and
he's still you know going out there
kicking some ass and it doesn't look
like this guy's gonna stop do you have a
number like do you say i think i'm gonna
go till this age or is it you know the
the diplomatic answer well we're gonna
see if we can take it one day at a time
we're going to talk to the family and
see that that's kind of the way i've
been through my whole career but i
always thought i wouldn't fight past 35
but at 35's almost you know i'm 32. i
was saying that when i was 19 20 years
old then you turned 32 and you're like
well i still feel pretty good 35 is not
that old you know but we'll see i i want
to be the world champion that that's the
goal and as long as i can compete with
these guys wake up feeling good of
course i have aches and pains i've been
fighting a long time but as long as i
can compete with these guys
i don't see why why why wouldn't
who do you see right now that's coming
up younger guys that's coming up where
you say that guy that guy's got a future
he could be a killer but the young guy's
coming up like the 21 year old version
of you is there any guys you're seeing
where you're
there are so many guys like that um
i trained at american top team in
coconut creek when i'm getting ready for
my fight it's not far from here
and there's just so many guys but but
also when i was 21 in the gyms the sport
wasn't nearly as big as it is now so the
amenities these gyms have the coaching
staff that these guys have we didn't
have that back then so i'm just seeing
the level of fighting getting so much
better you know
it the guys are starting at 16 15 years
old younger than that doing jiu jitsu
boxing doing mixed martial arts back
then we had to there wasn't a mixed
martial arts gym we had to go to a
boxing gym find a jiu jitsu gym travel
across town and try to put all the stuff
together ourselves mixed martial arts is
becoming its own
martial art now you have to be able to
do everything and these kids are doing
that from an early age so i'm just
seeing the level
grow so fast with these young guys man
they're incredible
you think ufc is going to pass up boxing
eventually where it's going to be just
more exciting to watch ufc unboxings
going to become a thing of the past or
you think boxing's always going to be
able to hang
i mean boxing's been around forever i
think ufc's gaining a lot of attraction
with combat sports fans in the in the
past few years
it might be that it might be at that
point right now you know
those big fights
the heavyweight championships of the
world you know anthony joshua tyson fury
deontay wilder those kind of fights are
always going to be prestigious you're
always going to want to see those fights
but the overall week to week month to
month fighting i think ufc or mixed
martial arts in general is doing bigger
things than boxing is yeah i think i
think many people would agree with you
how much of that you think is dana where
he had the startup mentality of a
barbarian seal you know coming up and
building that thing up how much of you
think it's more you know the fighters
coming like what kind of credit you give
for dana what he's done they did an
incredible job of building the company
up to what it is now
um cashing out on it
you know with two and a half billion
that was a nice payout i think they
bought it for two million so yeah they
bought it for four billion whatever
good for them though yeah that's the
best part the guy who you know the guy
that started it i don't know if you know
this or not maybe it's your world his
original plan was to create a cage fight
with sharks swimming around did you know
that story with i mean can you imagine
go too far shark swimming around it's
kind of a little weird but
you got a dana comes in with two of his
investors they buy it out and the rest
is history yeah i think a little bit of
it for sure is dana his marketing
ability his his
thoughts that he he made this to what it
is but
the fight sells itself because it's so
exciting that like i was talking about
variables there's so many ways to win
and lose in mixed martial arts that that
it's hard to to get a boring fight
did you did you follow basketball
growing up are you a guy that followed
baseball basketball football or football
football you did okay so who was the
commissioner when you were following
football before roger goodell who
are you did you follow a lot of the
commissioner stuff or no i didn't follow
okay
so a dana white what's his relationship
with the fighters you know and here's
what i mean by that is it is he the boss
boss like hey this guy's the boss we got
to make sure we're going based on what
he's saying does he build a relationship
is he his friendship guy does he tell
you the truth behind closers he didn't
show up today i don't know what that was
all about if you fight like this you
ain't gonna get the big fight what's his
relationship with fighters he's honest
like that okay if you go out there leave
it all out there don't play it safe
he'll bring you back
he's a pretty you know cut dry honest
guy when it comes to that type of stuff
i haven't spent a whole lot of time in
um you know with him i've gone to vegas
a few times and cut some deals where he
had to sit down with the lawyers and
stuff like that uh other other times
it's just been at events behind the
scenes you know quick chats but he's
honest uh in person
dana's yeah you almost see like the way
he uh deals with the fighters he seems
forgiven but he also seems like he's got
a pretty high standards on the way he
sets it up as long as you go out there
and fight as hard as you can you're in a
good spot with dana and it gets up with
dana because he gets the eyeballs so
crazy question for you just crazy
question this is just for my own
interest it probably has nothing to do
with the guys here if if dana if let's
just say comes to a time where dana
wants to retire walk away who does
dana's job
that's a tough tough spot to fill um
i'm not sure i think daniel cormier
maybe maybe somebody who's been in
combat sports i don't know if he knows a
whole lot about the business side
but i i think he would be a great face
of of a company daniel cormier yeah is
is daniel going to be able to poke and
challenge like uh like uh
dana does you think daniel could do
because you know dana's like
he will steer the pack because he knows
like even the one the best things i like
to watch is his uh post fight
conferences
so ticket uh sold out sixteen thousand
two hundred eight pay-per-view buys bone
uh fight of the night is this questions
and he goes and he says well i wasn't
too impressed i thought the judge is
this
what's sport boxing do you ever see
people talking about the judges sucked
everything's about protect the judges
and the referees he goes straight after
the judges for sure yeah interesting guy
can you see connor ever doing what he
does
connor connor
i don't know if uh
i can't speak on it i guess he could
he i guess he could a personality like
conor cause conor is you know uh he's a
great fighter but the guy's a great
smack talker as well yeah
but leading a company i'm not sure if
you'd want that
you know
got it okay
be in the face and the voice of a
company might get out of hand here and
then yeah so you need a diplomatic guy
that's that's yeah yeah maybe a little
bit of that somebody who stands their
ground but doesn't cross the line i
think that's cool and daniel definitely
stands the ground yeah yeah
yeah so okay so so we've talked about
dana we talked about a lot of those
things uh your business ventures so this
you fighting has also opened up a lot of
different opportunities for you you now
have businesses hot sauce you got
charities can you talk about what some
of the projects you're working on today
yeah the hot sauce
i love cooking and always wanted to have
some space in the culinary world and
during the last year during the pandemic
when we were at the beginning of like
march you know we were locked in the
house
that's when i started putting pen to
paper and and jotting down ideas and and
finding people who i can link up with
who were respected in that industry and
we put it together and and we launched
it um
january of this year
and it's doing very well man
the the hot sauce yeah got a bunch of
them out office by the way yeah yeah
yeah we got the hot sauce great yeah
yeah so hot sauce is purely because
you're cooking yeah i'm cooking i love
to cook but i'm also from louisiana and
we take our hot sauce serious in
louisiana yes it's like a religion over
there yeah louisiana hot sauce is a
special thing and i wanted and i was
just home and during the pandemic and
saw an opportunity to to
get in the culinary world
dustin how much does
does you
winning in your world that you're in
in the in the
ufc mma world that you're in how much
does this
create additional opportunities for you
outside of the world how much have you
seen that happen it's huge
you know because i'm already have a
spotlight with these fights and the
build up with these fights
and
for hot sauce um guys eating wings
watching fights the demographic that's
following the sport and my fan base it
was just a great timing and a great
thing um
it was a i knew it was going to be a win
from the jump
and my star in the ufc not only raises
that with the sales of the hot sauce but
it also gives me a platform to speak
about my charity and to speak about the
things we're working on and i want to
take advantage of that you know and when
the ufc moved over to espn i was excited
because i knew that just
i had a bigger megaphone now to get
these goals with my charity out
but definitely me fighting has created
opportunities no doubt about it
do you think if you would have tried to
do the hot sauce and the charity
when you're not in the top five or the
top ten it would have the same impact as
it does today do you think there was an
element of timing like let's wait to do
this when we got a bigger platform and
then let's launch it yeah
i i really believe that
at this time you know i'm fighting in
the biggest fights of the year all eyes
are on me so i really have an
opportunity to
take advantage of that and and so many
more people are hearing the news about
what we're doing with charity or hearing
the news about the hot sauce just way
more eyes on me and what i have going on
yeah it's very big because a lot of
times guys will you know try to do
everything at the same time too early
before they're way too big
and then you you don't have that big of
a impact right because you can't you
don't have the eyeballs on you yet
rather than let me go win here first and
then i can do the all the other you know
ancillary whatever additional things
that i want to do and sometimes these
become bigger than this yeah yeah so
looks like that's that was kind of your
strategy yeah i just it was a perfect
timing like you said perfect timing
fantastic uh a couple other questions
before
we finish up also talking about your
charity
is
coming up when you were coming up were
there guys and the only reason i'm
asking is because sometimes in business
there's a lot of people that are here
these guys all from across the world you
know got people here from netherlands
qatar here all across the country
sometimes you're coming up and there are
some guys that are better than you maybe
you fought somebody that had the ability
to be a champion one day maybe get at
your level one day and you kind of saw
them drift away
was there any instances like that where
you saw some guys that could be fighters
but they kind of made some mistakes and
they
you know nothing ended up happening with
them we don't know about their stories
yeah i do what were some of can you not
not specific stories but if you don't
mind sharing a couple examples there was
one guy i um
there's a documentary called fightville
it follows me since i was a young
fighter an amateur fighter kind of shows
my journey to the ufc but the name that
comes to mind when you're talking about
guys who went on a different path is is
a guy in that documentary
was a tough fighter you know hard worker
but just couldn't see he could have done
it he could have been there he could
have made money he could have been a
world champion he could have just
couldn't seem to pull it all together
and be consistent and and i saw him go
down a different road you know but he
had what it took
when he say different road what do you
mean he couldn't put it all together
meaning he couldn't stay disciplined was
it the association was it he couldn't
get rid of the bad friends was it
all of that all of them yeah all of
those things
is is there a is there a uh when i'm
talking to mike and i'm saying hey he
says you know when mike tyson talks
about the fact that my son says he wants
to be a boxer i said what do you mean
you want to be a boxer you live in a
multi-million dollar house you don't
have what it takes to be a boxer what
are you talking about go back to school
i didn't grow up going to private school
you do right like he has a conversation
with his son do you see
a
common
trend with guys who end up becoming
killers in your world do they have
similar upbringing like do you see a
trend with that yeah i i think from my
point of view too it's
there's not a lot of people who
fight just because they want to fight
you know this fighting is scary it's uh
nerve-wracking it's dangerous there are
people out there obviously
who who do it and can be successful but
most of the time fighters are
you're fighting because you have to
you're fighting your way out of
something fighting for your family to
have a better you know
way of life you're fighting just to make
a name for yourself
so a lot of these guys in these gyms
that i've noticed are guys from similar
backgrounds you know made some bad
mistakes
found a way to that they can work with
their hands
and
and make a name for themselves you know
all these guys are blue collar hard
workers for the most part and um they
they didn't have a choice they fought
their way you know literally
uh into a better life and i see that
across the board whether it's boxing or
mixed martial arts
you don't it's not like you're playing
football and you need pads and a helmet
and all you need to do is wake up and
have
hands and and you can shadowbox you can
go for a run you can start working on
skills you don't need a lot of equipment
a pair of gloves
and and you're you're on your way to
start training and i just think
that too is part of people um
you know you don't need a lot of money
to start learning how to fight
so there's an edge to the blue collar
mentality
right you have to big edge when you're
coming up you don't have anything you're
around you know you're in the streets
you see stuff that others are not going
to see it's almost like the survival
defeat is type of deal right and you can
and it's something special because you
can literally
fight your way out of
whatever
you know life has has whatever hand
you've been dealt you can literally
fight your way punch by punch into a
better life yeah do you have any kids i
have one daughter how are you going to
pass that down to your kids how do you
pass down the blue collar mentality so
that's the thing you just said like your
buddy lives in a multi-million dollar
house i don't want my daughter to fight
you know i don't want to see my daughter
well are you guys planning on having
more kids yeah okay so let's just say
you have a son like you i could pass it
down to him i'd rather him go to go to
college and
but uh
we'll see what happens i'll never tell
like try to direct them away from it but
i don't want to see that i i
but i will try to pass on the lessons
i've learned through fighting because
i've learned so much about myself um
through victory through losses through
business
i've been in rooms that i would have
never been in sitting across from from
people i would never be in front of
if i never put on a pair of boxing
gloves so i'm thankful for that that's
cool it's kind of me and so so your kids
if your son says that i want to be like
you when i grow up i want to do ufc i
want to do mma what do you tell the kid
i'm not sure man i uh
i will take it one day at a time we'll
take it one day at a time you know what
i don't want to think about that
conversation right now pat so but you
know uh going back to uh uh the ufc you
know
as a whole as an industry are you a fan
of yourself are you a guy that also
watches all the fights like you enjoy oh
yeah i watch everything always have them
who do you like like who is who's your
favorite you know fighters of all time
in the in the ufc
i used to be a huge fan of george st
pierre he's one of the guys who can do
it all you know and back around
when he was really starting to rise up
yeah they had a lot of guys a guy was a
grappler or a guy was a wrestler this
guy's a kickboxer he was one of the
first guys who really put everything
together and was a complete mixed
martial artist
world champion
held himself you know spoke well
and uh i was a big fan of george
st pierre you put him on mount rushmore
oh yeah he's on mountain who's on mma
mount rushmore you got is it khabib and
him and who else khabib's up there fedor
is up there fedor fedor
wow fedor's got to be up there
uh
jones has to be up there too so that's
the four yeah those are the four anybody
here watch fade or fight or no who
doesn't know yeah so you guys don't know
who fedor is oh my gosh
vader was
you could watch this if you just go type
in fade or f-e-d-o-r
you will be stuck to youtube for a
couple hours this guy's fights were
legit remember to fight with randall
yeah when he slammed did he slam him
yeah yeah yeah
fedor got slammed on his head he got
slammed on his neck you're thinking the
guy's dead yeah
dude they build them different in russia
russia
awesome well why don't we talk a little
about your charity and then we're gonna
have some of the guys ask some questions
here and then we'll go from there so
talk about your charity if you don't
mind my charity
me and my wife lived in florida here in
boca raton for five years and then my
daughter was born we moved back to
louisiana because i wanted to raise her
with family
but um
when we were moving i had these drawers
full of fight worn gear over the years
of fights like my first win in the ufc
my first win in the wec fights that just
meant these
these these things just meant something
to me
and it's cool when you have one or two
or three
but when you have 40 something fights
and your drawers are just full of bloody
gloves and clothes it's not cool anymore
it's kind of gross and we were moving
and packing up a u-haul and we're like
what are we gonna do with all this stuff
and we were just thinking talking and we
decided to auction some stuff off and
donate the money to a fallen officer
who had just passed away in the line of
duty right near uh where my wife and i
went to school in louisiana so we did
that and then we did it again did it a
few more times
and i was just doing that out of my name
like dustin donates some money dustin
does it and i was in training camp one
one day and we were talking and we
wanted to see if we can give it its own
identity and turn this into an actual
charity so it's not dustin does this
dustin does that we can turn it into
something that has its own name and see
if it can grow organically and other
people can get behind it and my goal was
to have other fighters donate their
fight war memorabilia and we can auction
it off or or sell it and do things in
their communities too
and we started the good fight foundation
and since then we've done some amazing
things i'm very proud of we're currently
building housing in uganda right now for
the pygmy people
we teamed up with manny pacquiao for
that goal awesome justin wren as well
yeah so that and we don't have one
specific goal we do all we do all kinds
of things whatever we see we can help in
the in the community or
wherever
it's a good fight foundation and that's
your 501c3 that's my favorite awesome
and also i have no
no background in starting a business or
building a website so me and my wife are
in training camp
um on a laptop computer trying to build
this website for the foundation we're
just starting and it's been a learning
thing man you know we we was running
like a mom-and-pop shop at the beginning
but it's it's cool because
we have full control of everything we
have still no paid uh no payroll we
haven't paid anybody there's no no
employees of the foundation it's just me
my wife two of our friends from
louisiana and and we're doing some
amazing things i'm very proud of it's
great well i got a gift for you at the
end uh that i'll announce it in front of
everybody and maybe we'll do something
special for dustin here but what i'd
like to do is open it up leop we have
the mike ceos so you got a question cody
tell us what question do you have for
dustin
we got 15 minutes to go through
questions here and leo's walking like a
turtle but it's great we'll figure it
out thanks leo
so rose namajunas had this uh i may not
pronounce her name right but she had
this like tradition she does where she
says i'm the best i'm the best i'm the
best which i love that clip by the way
and i'm sure a lot of people that watch
ufc saw that
do you do anything like this personally
i
i don't chant anything but i do have a
routine i do
during fight camp is i i
for my mental focus that might get her
in the zone what gets me in the zone is
i write down the date of the fight on a
piece of paper
i draw a circle around the date of the
fight and inside that circle i write
everything i have control of you know my
diet my uh my accountability my my
my commitment to training um just
everything that i can control and
outside of that circle i write
everything i can't control sick you know
inside that circle is my thoughts my
work ethic my commitment outside that
circle is
opinions critics
uh the media my opponent
and and i'll just go to that page in my
book throughout periodically throughout
my training camp and on fight week and
look at it
and i know i'm in a good spot because
all this stuff outside of that circle
doesn't matter that's just noise the
only thing i can focus on and affect or
the things inside of that circle so as
long as i'm doing that i'm doing the
most i can doing everything i can so i
just make sure that the inside of that
circle is taken care of
that's phenomenal unbelievable
yes john
[Applause]
awesome so to break that down even more
what are some
routines and habits that you have
preparing for a fight and then what are
some routines and habits you do
recovering from a fight and part two of
that or what are some distractions that
are coming up while you're preparing for
the fight
i'll tackle that part first the
distractions are um
just the the media and the critics and
you know social media is such a toxic
place but it's a place that i have to be
because i need to promote these things i
have businesses so i have to be on there
i don't have to read all the comments
and all this
but you still see them you know so so
that's always a big distraction people
saying and especially in fighting
we're preparing to fight each other and
you've got your opponent chirping all
the time saying crazy things
those things really used to get under my
skin and but i do the circle thing now
and i just focus on what i can control
so all those things that i'm reading are
out of my control
um
distraction besides that you know just
just the just the noise on the outside
of that circle
it kind of distracts me every now and
then but i can refocus on the center and
the first part of the question
holding myself accountable showing up
every day even on bad days even days i
don't want to go in i show up uh waking
up running the miles you know
checking the boxes
you know doing everything i think i need
to do to be the world champion as long
as i do those things i mean whatever's
going to happen after that is just going
to happen but i'm going into these
fights i'm walking down this this road
into the unknown as prepared as i think
i can be
you have a set schedule
oh yeah yeah when i'm in training camp i
have a set schedule we usually start at
eight weeks and we have different phases
and it phases into uh peaking for the
fight
interesting similar to bodybuilding by
the way very interesting let's go here
to joanna then i'm gonna go to a couple
guys here on the co side and maybe i'll
come to some of you is that tomorrow or
no maybe i'll come to you
hey dustin i'm big fan so thanks for
coming um in the last fight with connor
you said the initial leg injury happened
really at the beginning of the first
round so he actually kicked you and you
blocked the leg right and then second
time close to the first round the end of
the first round he used the leg again to
follow through with the punch right and
then obviously the fight ended because
of the injury did you hear anything did
you feel anything when you blocked the
leg how did you know that's when it
happened and the second question is he's
talking smack again saying he's going to
fight you again are you really going to
fight him again for the fourth time i
mean i will
if he can heal up and
if he can what i don't hear if he can
heal up if he can heal up got it
and they can add some commas on that on
the check i think
yeah
but
i didn't hear it break i didn't even
know it was broken until the end of the
round when i looked down and it was kind
of dangling yeah but
i just been throwing kicks for so long
so many thousands of kicks i've thrown
and
received that i know when a kick lands
bad i didn't get a full check on his
kick but i turned my my leg outward and
his shin bone hit my knee and i knew it
hurt him that's why at the beginning of
the fight i pointed at his leg and i
knew it hurt i didn't know it broke but
i knew it hurt i honestly think that it
fractured then and then later on it he
twisted or something and the bone yeah
broke but i did i didn't know it was
broken until the end of that round when
he was holding his leg
have you ever had that happen in a fight
to you before or no that was the first
time i've
yeah the first time something that bad
you know of course broken noses sure
broken hands things things like that but
i've never seen
me personally in a fight where
somebody's disfigured like that
historically who's recovered from that
anderson silva
um fought again you know fought two or
three more times after breaking his leg
he broke it after he kicked it like he i
fought on that card as well yeah he
he broke it the same kind of thing that
i think fractured his leg but it was
broke all the way through there yeah
that was i remember that fight i
remember that fight let's go over here
let's go over here
go to one more ceo right here
right there directorvo ops
hey justin two questions so one question
uh i saw you running was this like mask
like oxygen or something what is that
that was an oxy it was a altitude
simulator so it pulls a little bit of
the oxygen out of the out of the air
that you're breathing in through this
machine so your body's running on less
less oxygen and you're getting fatigued
a lot quicker
and the second question is so i saw you
saying one of the interviews that before
you come into the octagon you're praying
that you don't hurt like the other
person like too much but
are you like when you come to the
octagon are you like ready to dive like
are you ready to like
fight till the yeah i always pray that
me and my opponent
come out and go home to our family safe
because what we do is very dangerous but
when i walk in my feet touches that
canvas i'm willing to die in there yeah
i wanted to do whatever it takes to to
be victorious
yeah i am how do you not love this guy
like seriously
you can kick your ass but you love the
guy
right there right that that honest that
part scares me as well you know i
wouldn't sit up here and say i'm not
scared to death of making that walk but
i make it every time you know and when i
get in there i'm i'm willing to
whatever's going to happen i'm willing
to go through so does your does your
wife watch your fights or know when it's
happening live or no yes she does are
you comfortable watching them i didn't
have a car
i have 46 fights my first fight was 2006
or 2007. i didn't have a car she drove
me to my first fight she's been to she
watches all my fights wow
good for you seriously kudos
awesome go ahead buddy
hello to everybody i'm damian from
bulgaria i'm a professional wrestler so
i can uh i'm very respected by you sir
my question to ju to dustin is
when you were an amateur trying to make
it to the professionals what was your
mindset like and also when you made it
to professionals how did you balance
between your professional life as a
fighter and also family life thank you
when i was an uh amateur working my way
up i just knew i had to
get in front of the now the landscape is
changing mma is such a big sport now
that guys are kind of picking and
choosing fights to make sure they build
up their record but for me as an amateur
i wanted to fight the best guys i didn't
want to fight the guy with the losing
record i wanted to fight the best guys
build my name up and try to make it in
the ufc or get a call from the ufc
um so so that's what i did as an amateur
i took the toughest fights i can get and
also in the back of my head knew if i
made mistakes in these fights that it's
gonna my record is gonna be back to
zeroed out when i turned pro so i wanted
to learn as much as i could before i
made that step into professional
fighting i wanted to make mistakes
and and and get better
so i tried to fight a little bit longer
against tougher guys as an amateur
before i made the decision to turn
professional so did you take more risks
as an amateur because you're like let me
just see if i can do this or not i took
more risk because i needed to learn and
i knew in the back of my head that it
was my record was going to be zero great
when i go pro fantastic so you're
starting with zero and zero so it's not
like uh yeah it's we wipe that away no
we don't talk about amateur records you
know nobody's going to talk about
professionals yeah professional records
and then obviously when you go pro then
you want to fight guys that that
favorable matchups build your name up
and then fight the best guys in the
world but as an amateur i had the
opposite mindset i wanted to fight the
toughest guys sick
sick mindset tamara
tamara
she asks very technical questions so
we're hoping it's less than 15 seconds
funny you say that i have so many
questions maybe i can ask guests the
questions next time if you allow me no
problem
you are hired i believe in you
so i'm a huge ufc fan i grew up watching
ufc on the weekends and
when i was thinking about what kind of
question to ask well first of all i have
so much respect for you dustin and for
everyone who works and fights in the ufc
because not only you give it all
financially you also give it all
health-wise
so so much respect for you
my question um does everybody know who
donna white is
okay so i was watching donna white's
interview on candice and one thing that
he said is
when my
guys fight in the octagon i don't care
who they think allah or jesus who they
believe in democrats or republicans how
come is that the most violent industry
in an octagon is so peaceful in a
political arena
that's a tough question
and
the question is for you for patrick and
dustin
i didn't hear the second part
the question is for both of you guys if
patrick also wants to answer i think
he's qualified i'm just gonna commentate
please great question by the way it is i
think it's such a um diverse talent pool
from fighters and athletes from all over
the world that there's no room for you
know
for hate or for
everybody's coming from around the world
and fighting in ufc it's not like a one
country sport so many walks of life so
many religions
how could they have barriers you know
you can't when
ever everybody's so different in
fighting and and they they couldn't put
up barriers that i think that's why
everybody just accepts each other
and by the way if it happened it
happened a little bit on the counter
fight with khabib right there was a
little bit of that and that was
the ufc world was not happy about that
they were not supportive about that like
listen you can call out a lot of things
wives you know certain things got to be
off limits and conor breaks all of those
rules by the way yeah that's definitely
crossing the line yeah
great question tamara okay anybody here
on ceos founders let go let's go over
here
leo if you don't mind running like yeah
just go over there bud okay
thank you all right that's fine let's
have a massive questions okay cool thank
you leah so
my my my question is uh in reference to
emotions so how important is controlling
your emotions in the octagon an octagon
or again
how do you process that i know a lot of
times in the business world we get good
news but more times than not we have to
deal with bad news
it's for me i'm an emotional person so
you know i'm very emotional a fighter
and i try to use that to work for me but
there's been so many fights that have
been over emotional and that that blind
that has blinded me and and
made me bad make bad mistakes during the
fight kind of like a
just so angry that i'm doing things that
that i shouldn't i'm getting away from
technique because i'm fighting on
emotion
but i i had a trainer tell me one time
after a fight that
these emotions are like a fire like you
can use them
they can burn you
or you can use them to to cook your
family's meals and i kind of took that
with me wow and i'm just trying to to
use that fire to to to push me forward
in training to push me to make me focus
because before i walk out there and
fight when i'm in the locker room i'm
just i'm nervous
and i'm scared but i just over these
past years of fighting on such big
stages and so many times i realized that
it's okay to be nervous and scared i'm
supposed to be because my body is
preparing itself to do something great
you know greatness should should make
you nervous and make you scared and make
you emotional so i just try to embrace
it i'm not absent to it i'm just
acquainted with those feelings
i'm not absent to it i'm acquainting to
those feelings
the level of depth on your answers is
dustin this is just
great right there go ahead
hey dustin uh i wanted to ask you talked
earlier about your camp and how you kind
of do the peak week
and i'm also a competitive bodybuilder
and as pat said
the prep is kind of similar in many ways
so as you go through prep and intensity
kind of builds up
and the emotional
you know i guess tension and the fatigue
and everything kind of builds up
especially if things in life around you
really kind of
apply pressure i would say yeah do you
have any systems things you do or that
you think of besides that
thing with the circle that keeps you
focused that makes sure that you're
always on point
making the right choices the right
decisions
so you can come to the fight
as
best as you can so you could perform the
highest level and win the fight
yeah i think
we just have to for me the circle you
said but
if you know your why like if you wake up
every day knowing oh i want to be the
world champion but that's just part of
it i'm a provider and i want my daughter
to grow up and have things i didn't have
i want my wife and daughter to be in a
safe spot i think that is my driving
force that pulls me back in because as
it ends training camp starts to end and
i do start peaking
i i i do get things do you know bother
me more i'm i'm trying to be laser
focused on this day coming up because we
have a date circled and every day's a
day closer i'm worried about am i
prepared enough that i do everything i
can possibly done
but that why is is
i'm going to go out there and do
whatever i need to do because i have a
wife and daughter at home and
how do i you know that that's that's
what i pull back to that helps me i
don't know if you have something like
that that anchors you but that's my
anchor you know i would do whatever it
takes to to make sure that they're good
we're going to do one more here and then
we're going to wrap up right here to the
left last question hey dustin hello my
name is juan martinez and uh you know i
just want to tell you you know when you
kick
the irish guy's ass
i was so happy to see and just shut his
mouth
and uh you know but your humbleness
your humbleness after the fight you
mentioning
your foundation
it really got to me
as an immigrant i came to this country
when i was 16
and it was people like you that make
donations
you know i didn't have any family or
nothing
and the american people were very
generous you know and i received
donations
now i'm in a
different
position
you know those people impacted me
uh as a child and here i am you know
a company successful along with my wife
and i wanted to on behalf of my family
make a thousand dollar donation to your
foundation so you could uh thank you to
help those people thank you so much does
make a difference
and i would encourage anybody else you
know let's raise 10 20 000 for his
foundation
thanks buddy
uh uh gang first of all how many guys
had a blast with dustin let's make some
noise for dustin i got two gifts for you
i got two gifts for you can we get the
gifts please so which one's this one i
know what this is
and what's this one
this is what
okay i got it so i'm going to give them
this year first of all we we know you
like this you may want to open it up and
see
what it is i think you'll like that
um
this is also yummy open this one
okay so you're a whiskey guy no i am so
we got you some nice whiskey for you oh
you're the man thank you and then we got
you you want to open this up so we can
show them what this is and then outside
of this i got one other gift for you
hang on
so we got a nice little custom
bottle for you to put your whiskey in
with valuetainment for coming through
decanter thank you so much and on top of
that brother we love you so much thank
you on the charity side i personally i
mean obviously we you you came over here
this is not like you're selling anything
this is not a pitch fest but twenty
thousand dollars from you to your
charity to support what you're doing
seriously what you're doing we support
you brother and we're gonna encourage
everybody else to support and figure out
how to do that we got twenty thousand
dollars from us for you thank you so
much make some noise that's the point
thank you
so dustin podia how he mentally gets
ready for the fight with the whole
circle what he can't control what he
cannot control kirsten know what you
took away on what he said about the
connor like is conor's still in a
position to fight and the fact that he
thinks he can fight anybody who you
think he needs to face off next comment
below and if you enjoyed this interview
i think you're also going to like the
interview i did with mike tyson and mike
probably told some stories i've never
heard before so if you want to watch
that click here to watch tyson's
interview thank you everybody bye
[Music]